hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to pop goes I'm going
back in I have no plan I've come up with
nothing to fix this or beat this I have
no idea I don't know how the Badger
works but I just got to play badger
badger badger on loop until it goes away
do I gotta like put on a badger suit
blend in with the Badgers I don't know
what I'm gonna do if you tell me I could
do it I don't know it's so not
explanatory how do we do any of this it
was some kind of battery thing I ran out
of power that's what it looked like but
I don't even know how I do the power
thing what are the powers made where are
the colors no no the colors
[Music]
oh [ __ ] punch
oh oh god I'm so not doing guy oh hi
okay so I'm gonna rope you you carry on
you do your thing you do your thing
buddy okay he's gone
great good Oh what did you do what was
that what you doing there what excuse me
why were you there where what did the
badger doing there well yellow called
[ __ ] up that call the Badger okay I
don't know what I did but I think I
helped it I'm not on represent your word
no no no no god damn it hey hi
I called job we're gonna look away now
ooh a mysterious how that badger just
appeared out of nowhere I don't know
what that is old Alvin you still there
oh great it's yellow okay don't like
that don't like that at all I'm gonna go
with a big old no on that one I want to
go with I hate that that's awful and
don't do that a big ol [ __ ] you go away
forever and die that'd be that'd be
lovely if you did that yes why is my
panic not going away why is my pee enemy
and okay it's going down okay all right
whatever yeah I shut down oh I finally
caught one of you you freaking [ __ ]
well you know where the other girls are
with all the ladies at no Frick it dick
oh my god this is insanity
how would you do any of this this is
only the third night I'm only a blonde I
am stop that where's the oh there you
are okay well I got you Sam for 10
seconds whatever hey stop that
no well I can't do anything about that
I'm gonna go with green pull badger hi
well you know alrighty then well I'll
see you okay you just have a good ol
time they're gonna pretend like you
aren't there
there's no badge behind me doodly-doo
I'm totally fine yeah doodlee okay Scott
where is the other guy man this
nightmare don't know you get heated get
Gordon
banished by the power of e you never
thought I'd have my heat transferred
into weapon form for animatronics no
really weapons one like defensive armor
you get don't do that whatever you're
doing whoever you're conspiring for
don't do it I that's pink
I got you call the badger I've got a
badger problem probably to my lip yep I
got a badger okay well that's a thing
that I deal with eventually gonna ignore
that problem bury it deep down it'll
never arise again right nope you're
still there Wow how about that you'll
kill me I think this bouncers gonna kill
me I don't need to worry about anything
else killing me when I get a badge or on
call uh-huh you still there well good
okay he's got alrighty then sorry hey
what a helpful badger where's this guy
go he's gone don't kill me I don't even
know what I'm doing how do you have so
many goddamn pieces the Freak are you
being even were you even the being stop
go nowhere you'd do the opposite of
movement just eat dicks
I don't care god damn it did you get
another piece kind of piece piece it's
so officious a cap to the flag
[ __ ] you oh I saw that vent camera oh
you get heat okay you're never gonna
survive this it's only 2:00 a.m. and the
[ __ ] oh did anybody how should anybody
how could anybody
I just gotta what I gotta do is I gotta
be more efficient about my panic time
right you know what I mean you know I'm
talking about you know I'm sluice laying
you know I'm sayin yeah you know what
I'm sayin I just gotta keep my panic
down that way I'm less stupid about
everything that I'm doing you heat up
got that so that's the the other key you
just got to get those as often as
possible okay green call okay guy got a
badger you
shut down your there well alright hello
okay hey lady okay doodlee okay alright
well you're there I'm gonna look over
here now all right where'd you go
still in there good you stay there
please oh okay
panic panic panic during the panic away
panic oozing away all my problems
doodlee Lu doo de doo doo doo doo doo
okay stilling that good sheep okay team
a panic down the badgered back ma'am I
got a serious badger problem can you fix
this
no get he'd blue oh he's sucking my
power right out of me I don't know if I
need to check on you but I'm doing it
just to be polite
I want someone just staring at me out of
the blue you know you still there hi
ladies who get some heat still there oh
hey you doing okay well that's a thing
that happens and exists in this world
but I got a better lock on this now that
I got a rhythm and a pattern going I'm
kind of doing a little better heat okay
and by heat I mean deadly lasers are you
and I know you're somewhere here no
really not panic down he likes that one
he likes that one he really likes that
one he really likes that one and I don't
know I personally I think it's a little
contrived punky don't keep all the bad
you know I don't know if I'm gonna make
it this time it's only 3 a.m. but doing
better
Maji how you going ok good for you what
the [ __ ] I saw chica did you guys just
no not not that not that
ok got that too bad he doesn't have
another part doesn't have another part
don't good there the panic down you need
heat okay
well really likes Alan I think I got a
lucky streak here because if you only
goes to the same one over and over again
well then he's gonna tricks beyond that
one and it's not gonna be as easy funk
okay I got him locked down pretty good
there I see chicken yeah he wants he
wants that one
maybe it's like maybe
he can only get a body part from certain
ones of them and the fact that I
currently right now have both of them on
like on lock like they're both in the
same spot so it kind of works out real
good ly for me you know what I'm saying
yeah it kind of works out real nice like
you know I mean not that a few other
button presses wouldn't be too bad but
you know so long as I don't have to look
at anything else I mean oops oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] no that and that okay yeah as long
as I don't flip up the button boo-boos
or perch goober
give me that pink boink boink that
sounded weird but you know I'm gonna
stick with it blink okay yeah I think it
is I think he only gets certain body
parts from certain places and therefore
if he can't if you can't get it from one
he's just gonna keep going back to it
right that's what makes sense I think
anyway so he needs like does he need the
body
he's the body in the head so what that
means is that must be either the body or
the head printer double checking just to
be sure you never know with this [ __ ]
yeah he's there right locks loaded
Oh what are you doing what's color oh
look going L all your quick response
time is amazing with this guy okay 5
a.m. if I keep this up I think I win I
think I win one Hey still there okay
that's weird you know you can go about
now now it's like we're gonna call a
repairman to your apartment and they
just kind of hang out for way too long
you still there buddy aw kid good all
right good thing you [ __ ] off really
appreciate that that's my favorite part
of the day is when you [ __ ] off lasers
all right a little more a little more a
little more come on
lasers double lasers epic ultra laser
combo don't do any of that you're still
in there okay he's not in there okay no
God look how the game yeah they didn't
break absolutely [ __ ] everything I
bet it did keep okay okay it's a panic
down and then we're good to go
[Music]
all right let's see whatever their
horrible nightmare is awaiting me in the
land of the tentacles and veins yeah you
be oh look at this chubby cheeked piece
of garbage yeah let's see where you're
going
are you a weasel or are you Blake the
buy a juror that I know and frankly I
don't care I'm gonna go see if I need to
say I did chica which should be up and
to the right maybe up and straight would
be good I don't exactly know I'll find
out oh it's open the path is open to me
so this is what it is I gotta find all
of them in there horrible horrible
prison of death and
Vadnais oh no oh no that's her beak oh
that's her beak those are beacon or bib
on the floor greatest combo I could
think of Oh chica okay well alright
those are all the toy versions that's
the interesting thing to think about
this those are all the toy versions so
whoever made these pop-goes things is
the same creator of all those toy
versions of the animatronics because
you'll remember five nights at Freddy's
2 and the toy versions were there is
actually in the past so those weren't
made by the same person that made the
original so I think that's what pop-goes
is going for like this is an offshoot
all right how am I gonna die
oh look at these cute figurines I'm
gonna immediately start into this aren't
I what what believe it or not
an entire encyclopedia doesn't clear
anything up oh [ __ ] he's already got
another piece of the shadow bond
oh I'm boned hi okay alright sorry did I
interrupt you I'll look away now thank
you for being an [ __ ]
badger have you been there the whole
time [ __ ] weasel [ __ ] you [ __ ]
[ __ ] weasel piece of [ __ ] you do you
douche with your stupid scavenger hunt
of [ __ ] using technology you know if
this is
the future we're all looking forward to
a bunch of robots being [ __ ] and
then making more of themselves that's
what we can look forward to all this
technology Elon Musk and all the [ __ ]
they're just going for this you know
they're all doing it's like it's not a
you know it's not even it's not even
cool it's just like stupid right oh I
didn't even see you making that you
piece of ass [ __ ] you it's what I'm
trying to say is a whole bunch of
[ __ ] and I don't like you with your
stupid fastness are you fast where are
you all hi hello whelp is friendly over
here how can I see a little bit of you
well oh why was the badger that wide
that's fine I don't like that that is
not good I don't have a phone Wow my
brain got munched well Elsa what's with
this connection lost thing right robot
robot your robot it might be a robot
anyway that's all the time I got for
this now thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think down
the comments below I will finish this
very soon and as always I will see you
next video
[Music]